das ist kaufleute das ist wirklich krass
dass dieser satz immer noch im internet
unterwegs ist oder dass überhaupt jemand
weiß dass ich diesen satz gesagt habe
[Musik]
es kommt zu einem neuen video heute
hätte ich mein wissen über mich selbst
max und lukas wir nicht geringer mai
stimmt warum ich muss schon wieder
werden blogger an machen da kann man
sich nicht geben auf diesen seiten ein
schlanker bauch trägt starter wochen
veröffentlicht besitzer ich habe schwer
blickt wer klickt auf eine werbung wo
das steht werden wir weiter machen
wollen
bisher wissen was wir machen wollen
glaubte wohl mit hoch und die erste
frage haben etwa klingen allerersten
kompakter gerettet weil wenn die person
seite über die betrifft diese natürlich
gute sache denn wir wollen anfangen blut
noch nicht gerettet glaube ich für
dieses wir hatten ja etwas zugestoßen da
kann man die ganze vielfalt der apa der
waffe der ersten satz den er jemals
gesagt hat das ist auch leute das ist
wirklich krank wie gesagt immer noch im
internet unterwegs ist oder dass
überhaupt jemand weiß dass ich das
gesagt habe ich hab schon irgendwie die
marktleute ich kann es immer wieder
betonen wie griff niemand vergessen
das internet vergisst nicht erst recht
wenn der youtuber seid dann seid alle
zimmer und ich würde ich selbst schon
erfahrung gemacht mit bildern des netzes
gepostet habe die ich dann lieber nicht
hätte pforten sie sagt wenn der youtuber
seid wenn ihr irgendwie eine gewisse
reichweite hat oder selbst vielleicht
nur eure freunde vollmer für welche
plattform bietet ein nicht gar nicht was
ich irgendwie in die bredouille bringen
könnte denn irgendein arsch speichert
immer regel nur einzelne jetzt irgendein
arsch speichert immer dann kann ich
sagen da der erste satz war sebastian
marx bei wer von den dreien hat als
erstes den mersey beat genutzt boleslav
mit max oder luca ich habe ihn auf jeden
fall mal benutzt macht zusammen benutzt
wer ihn richtig gegeben penetration
versteht ihr vor als möchte von allen
guten geister ich sag einfach mal das
war mag ich glaube von max herre ich
gesagt da nach zwei kommt drei alter wie
fest kann seinem leben frage nummer drei
die nachfrage nummer 4 kommt da als
spanischer a
das sind richtig durch die heißen lukas
maskottchen die kelle balu kollege
ökologie und einzelne wörter deutsch
aber okay er hat keine ukulele und balu
gibt playboy ich war zu hause und er hat
auf jeden fall diesen fetten goldenen
play button auch augen auf gequält da
darf man auch noch ok es wird euch
vorstellen wenn jemand in die bude kommt
und nicht weiß der junge youtuber ist
sollte vor einer vereine wurde
für paul scholl oder so eine wand steht
an der wand einfach so ein glaskasten
mit augen drauf als ich vermute mal
weiter diesen dingen auch augen
aufgeklebt hat ja ich schaue nicht jede
von lukas videos vermutlich aber
trotzdem mal das ist lady ist dieses
ding und gibt deswegen als normal
eigentlich müsste ich ja diese clips
über max luca nicht geht eigentlich
schon ein paar punkte holen wenn ihr
jetzt das thema gemacht hat und mich
dann ab zog punktemässig dannigkeit
menschen existenz nicht abstoßen
[Musik]
das haben wir doch nie als ob wir das
schon mal gesagt haben das sind wirklich
krasse insider in welchem video sagt
irgendjemand zu euch was ihr auch
bestimmte welche videos gesagt hat könne
man die kommentare schreibt der insider
formieren mag ist es ist karneval und es
ist karneval maxi idee für das was man
sagen leute wenn man von der polizei
angehalten wird man zum beispiel ohne
führerschein fährt ist auf dem pferd
irgendjemanden angeschossen hat er
alltägliche dinge dann sollte man der
politik sagen hey ich dachte keiner
weiter wir uns vorgestellt was die
polizei so sollte es doch gleich
angefangen so weiter macht hat ökologie
etwas mit dem clever bot yao politik
kamerun nahm in einem excel budget vor
und luke lücker yaacool wurde quasi vom
clever bord erfunden
er ist ein kollege haben ohne namen
vorgeschlagen
meinst du gewerkschaft frage nummer 7
wer von ihnen hat ein neues auto video
gemacht lupe und sk sk lookout markt
oder luca und das liebe leute ist einer
der leichteren tage für mich luca hat
damals ein video gemacht mit dem 911 gts
den er damals hatte fünf wochen sollen
blauer und ich habe ein video mit einem
jaguar s-type gemacht hat wünschte
wirklich mein auto auf dementsprechend
waren das natürlich luca und ellington
jay war die 34 bykowski ja alle drei
flusstäler das war damals die coole
cruiser volker kugel werden die drei als
triangle geschäft natürlich nur max und
luca und frage zu luca hat schon mal ein
quiz stellt yahoo alles klar
neun von zehn aufgaben richtig
beantwortet im durchschnitt haben die
künstler für die us küste macht haben
viele kommen 31 richtige antworten geben
das heißt ich kenne mich selbst besser
ist eher durchschnittlich kennt aber
dafür gibt es leute die im video wie den
radlern wie sollten die shipment von max
luger mehrheiten hatten die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal nach oben fliegt
red